vivimos tiempos en los que la tecnología
está cambiando todo en nuestras vidas
excepto a las escuelas hace 100 años las
escuelas no eran muy distintas a las que
tenemos hoy en día y el único resultado
de este modelo industrial de educación
es que no satisface a nadie pues la
cinta transportadora sigue su marcha a
la misma velocidad provocando que en
eeuu un alumno de nivel medio deje la
escuela cada 26 segundos nuestros
alumnos se merecen algo mejor se merecen
una educación que puedan personalizar
para sus necesidades específicas y que
todos ellos alcancen su potencial máximo
y se preparen para una economía post
industrial el concepto de aprendizaje
combinado puede tener ese potencial y lo
importante de esto es recuperar lo mejor
de las escuelas tradicionales y
combinarlo con el poder transformador
del aprendizaje en línea para que cada
alumno adquiera una educación de acuerdo
a sus necesidades líderes y educadores
de eeuu y otros países están conscientes
de que el aprendizaje combinado genera
escuelas mucho más individualizadas más
interactivas y en última instancia más
exitosas a favor de
alumnos soy bryan greenberg y dirijo el
fondo de inversión de escuelas de
silicon valley somos una fundación para
el aprendizaje combinado pasé los
últimos 20 años en las trincheras de la
educación como maestro director y
director académico investigando lo que
funciona en la escuela y otros espacios
alternativos y yo soy michael hartnett
director ejecutivo del programa
educativo del instituto clayton
christensen somos un tanque de ideas no
lucrativo enfocado en la innovación para
la educación y desde el principio hemos
investigado el campo de la educación
combinada ofrecemos este curso que es
básicamente una introducción al
aprendizaje combinado pero con una
salvedad importante nos interesa la
educación combinada de alta calidad no
sólo poner la tecnología en la cúspide e
instalar computadoras en el salón de
clases sino la gente que rediseña las
estructuras y los conceptos básicos de
cómo funciona la educación para hacerla
más atractiva a los alumnos que sea un
proceso más eficaz y lograr que el
estudiante se apropie cada vez más del
proceso de aprendizaje
seremos tus guías en este curso y te
vamos a presentar algunos
líderes mundiales en aprendizaje
combinado también vamos a mostrarte tres
escuelas que actualmente practican la
educación combinada para que te
familiarices con tres modelos distintos
nuestro objetivo es proporcionar te lo
necesario para que experimente es el
aprendizaje combinado ya seas maestro
director de escuela trabajes en
tecnología o sólo quieras aprender más
sobre el aprendizaje combinado así que
únete a este movimiento para formar el
futuro de la educación aprende de los
pros y contras del aprendizaje combinado
de calidad y aprende del aprendizaje en
línea tomando un curso en línea